and the first line and fourth line remain the
same between the second and third some juggling
act among the players there shifting a few guys
around in carbury this afternoon Wilson from the
severe angle Stuart Skinner was pinned to the post
oetkin keeps it alive twist one towards the cage
wide Skinner reacting late he didn't track that
all that well from the point dry sidles headman
Leon dry to the corner angled and finished by
the great eight dry Sidle sends it for nurse
nurse's Drive steered Away by linden the Ricochet
clicked off of Kane and just bounced wide longtime
Nashville Predator blue liner to the corner boards
Nick Dow gets top side slap pass from sandine to
Carlson stick save Skinner lingren will hold
Charlie Linden was the net minder of record in
both Washington wins over Edmonton a season ago
yeah you have to be acrobatic I think in the gold
pending Department a glorious chance for the Caps
to get a lead just a shank off the heel of the
stick bad turnover by the Edmonton Oilers Winston
de har is 73 in the white no Philip broberg for
the guy wearing three in the blue today Dow
Ventures back ran into McDavid highman closing
off of a two-goal performance a backhander stick
save for lingren McDavid didn't drag it from the
pack Point position here Carlson to sandine from
the angle no worries for Skinner with a blocking
[Applause] glove
well they're one of the highest scoring teams
in the first Peri but it goes downhill from
there if you can get through the first period
that's a real positive against this Oiler team
obey cuell along the wall this drives right on to
lingren he has six saves under his belt to this
point
[Applause]
[Applause] dry Sidle back to the point kolak
for de har All on the perimeter dry cidal
getting wide to protect the puck against o
cubel on his backand to the front sprawling
stop rebound they score deposited in tight by
Evander Kane that's a hard workking goal and
it all starts with dry Sidle and you're stuck
man on man it was obey cubel against dry cidal
he got a step on him here's that last play
there's the puck to the middle there's one
stop but he can't control the rebound in front
of the net see all the mannerisms from Charlie
linger I think he wants to review here I think he
does too Lexia fell into him Kane coming through
the paint or maybe the matter is are no no no
don't challenge I'm not sure which it is well
Kane jabed at his body definitely and then
Alexia fell into him he's I think washing
out the goal but he's not going to get that call
here he was in great position there as lingren
latches on with a glove 535 remain in Period
one nen Hopkins that goes High didn't miss by
much an excellent three-way passing play when
they get into the Zone they're a speeded pass
see the combination work this one batted in from
below the crossbar it's two nothing nen Hopkins
on the board yeah you can see that it popped up
over Charlie's right shoulder and came out that
side of the net neuton Hopkins just waited and
batted here it is in front here's the little
play might but David watch it wait till it comes
down and that's pretty tight there close to the
crossbar height but they signal a goal there's the
stick sandine knocking in bid air you can see the
[Music] goenda newon Hopkins for the white
jersey Oilers back in the first lard who's
the power play quarterback leans into a blast
he scores The Scouting Report says he has a
rocket uh-huh well you mentioned that in the
first period and there you see remnance of
it in and out in a hurry 7 seconds after the
draw next to lingren and Bard from downtown
he hammers it home Bard's got his fth on
the power play here it is through Dow and
through a big Hyman screen give credit
to Hyman he took away the eyes of the
there and we're going to have another minor
penalty it looks like here for the Caps or
unsportsman likee we'll wait and see what the
call is going to be but there's a Bard shot
and the ERS are up three to nothing
Edmonton has the first three of this
afternoon give and go dry sidal had that
one snap wide move it for buard the most
recent on the score sheet Luen Hopkins skip it
on through feed it there turning dral for love
that is a superstar goal I mean the way he
spins and shoots that puck is unbelievable
passing sequence watch the pucko down little
watch him catch it on his backand turn to his
forehand Ricochet to me off the stick and tip
of Tom Wilson stick just slightly and it gets
past the glove and blocker there trying to
get his first goal so he can move as fast
as anyone with the pucky delivered through a
couple of Defenders here they come again net
Hopkins bang bang great glub save will David
stifle this one the catching my a beauty by
lingren what a save late here in this second
period there you see the shot and there you
see that overall the Caps have won six of their
last eight in this building we mentioned this
finishes up a four game h stand they've done
well against Edmonton here too lekin fires
it trickles off the outside of the post no goal
Alex oetkin few moments ago on the man Advantage
ding another seam pass for dry Sidle when
you think they're going to shoot they pass
and when you think they're going to pass they
shoot very deceptive power play MC David to the
front deflection great save by lingren followup
chance they score dral again right under the bar
with lingren down absolutely nothing Charlie
could do on that power play way lots of Zone
time and it takes him about 46 seconds a hot
hand watch the left side of the screen there
he goes through the seam he collects his own
Puck rotates up high and he going to click it
to the wall here and here comes dry settle
down low there's the shot to the front the
Puck's going to bounce out right there McDavid
I think will get the primary assist but along
with Hyman that should be on the board there
there you see a glove fly up in the air but
eyesight one six of their last eight overall
on this ice cheap eoles serves it along the
boards loose in front here and a backand glove
save Skinner robs mantha to they against the
Caps catches it in his big catching M look at
the missed assignments four different Oilers
on the puck side squirts out just about a two
on0 with Conor McMichael tries to go upstairs
Skinner State as the horn sounds it's a
shut out performance for Stuart Skinner
it's a setback for Charlie lingren in the
capitals Washington Falls to 105 and two